en méxico 13 de cada 20 latas son
recicladas qué porcentaje de latas es
reciclado escribamos esto tenemos 13 de
cada 20 latas 1320 a vos o 13 sobre 20
digamos que estas 13 latas son
recicladas pero el universo que tenemos
son 20 es decir tenemos 20 latas y sólo
13 de ellas son recicladas qué
porcentaje es reciclado este 1320 a vos
literalmente significa 13 entre 20
tenemos el numerador entre el
denominador 13 entre 20 en este caso los
números serán más pequeños que 1 porque
el número más pequeño va a ser dividido
entre el número más grande así es que
hagamos de este lado la división
tendremos 13
entre 20 buenos ya sabemos que este va a
ser un número con decimales
porque como les decía el numerador es
más pequeño que el denominador y veamos
empecemos puse unos ceros para agregar
precisión
20 cuántas veces cabe en 13 pues 0 0 por
20 0 13 menos 0 es igual a 13 y
bajaremos el primer 0 que está después
del punto decimal 130 es más grande que
20 cuántas veces cabe 20 en 130 pensemos
en
6 por 20 es igual a 120
se 130 los restos 120 tendré 10 y bajar
el siguiente
ahora tenemos 100 entre 20 será igual a
5 porque porque 5 por 20 es igual a 100
100 menos 100 es igual a cero tenemos de
residuo cero así es que si esto lo
pusiéramos como decimales pudiéramos
decir que 13 entre 20 es igual a 0.65
centésimos pero nosotros no nos están
preguntando la versión en decimal sino
el porcentaje y esto es también mucho
muy sencillo una vez que tenemos el
decimal simplemente multiplicaremos por
este número por ciento recuerden lo
multiplicaremos por 100 para sacar el
porcentaje lo multiplicaremos por 100 o
simplemente recorreremos dos veces
el punto decimal ya que estaríamos
multiplicando por 10 y por 10 y de esta
manera completamos el por 100 así es que
será 65%
y sé todo el recorrido pero también
podemos pensarlo de una manera mucho más
rápida y esta sería la siguiente manera
tenemos 13
de cada 20
13 latas de cada 20 nosotros habremos de
multiplicar por algún número este 20
para que nos diera el 100 el 100 por
ciento que en número será aquel que
estará sobre 100 por ciento porcentaje y
para que nosotros lleguemos a esa
respuesta hemos de multiplicar este 20
por algún número para llegar a 100 pero
recuerden que para tener la ecuación
equivalente hemos de multiplicar tanto
el numerador como el denominador así es
que también multiplicaremos ese 13 por
el mismo número
por cuánto de multiplicar 20 para
convertirse en 100 pues por 5 20 por 5
es igual a 100 ahora entonces este 13 lo
multiplicaré también por 5 5 por 3 15
5 x 15 más una que llevábamos son 6 y de
esa manera tenemos 65 de cada 100 lo que
es igual el 65%
y estamos en la misma respuesta entonces
en méxico 13 de cada 20 latas son
recicladas qué porcentaje de la tasas de
reciclado 65%
nos vemos en otro vídeo